welcome to this video again on Christmas
an additional 15 minute game and well
not much I can do about that but the
opponent is serrated almost how many
points is that 600 points no one this is
quite amazing the poor of player some
going for 15 minute chess must be
completely dried out here today okay
well he played a London sister with
Bishop f4 very solid way to play not
especially exciting but of course not
not bad law I am a chosen flexible set
up not playing d 50 d so I'm similar to
the Queen's Indian now let's see
probably takes with the upon yep then
going from a hedgehog set up this is
some a setup I am I recommend against
the the London a good a good point of it
is that you can very often um establish
enough control over if five so logically
play 65 okay but first I need to address
before this is some a very uncommon move
in this structure because it it very
much we can sleep on however it needs to
be exploited first and if white managers
to go see for it's not so bad hmm then I
came well if I go night
52 a Tekkit he will play queen bee three
and then see for nexus is not helping at
all if I go is 65 not hmm probably night
see form okay i just put the Queen on a
good square connecting oops I mean a
good square hmm yeah it's also in this
diagonal h22 system but what can you do
can't have everything young i wonder if
i should play a fire but that man I
should probably only play a five if
after seafoam
moon strategically speaking be five
would be a good move for me but he just
over he just protects p5b five to
establish a piece on d5 but it's it's
not clear how I how I should should
manage to play that push up to c6 yeah
he can maybe just just play b5 ok let's
let's put him I'm not sure how to place
my pieces yeah well up to this point he
hasn't played too badly not stuff like
them better here hmm
yeah Quinn 28 always a funky maneuver
note that night c4 is bad here because
of Bishop to g5 that's a really ugly
self pen okay
y la five is the still normal reaction
yeah very direct play on b5 ahead 'if
I've yeah I have our time to believe it
if it's that this is good but maybe
let's take here first yeah I think I can
just take twice and now take with the
night I don't really see any
compensation yeah but I can really just
take I don't really get it I mean it can
also take with the rook both I wasn't
both a possible no but should be aight i
just take before
yeah this is just an exchange and a poem
on any Queen move on yeah in some cases
I could even consider Bishop to g6 just
exchanging some material other than that
just queen a 7 or queen age next move
depending what what he's doing yeah he
doesn't really have a good move yeah
against that I'll go Bishop t6 get get
rid of the bishops here
yeah well he probably should take a
plane I'd see for something like that
mmm didn't do it okay jackets wrap it
and now maybe the ice is blooming up the
spin probably this one there's a good
idea attacking g2 and getting rid of the
the pin once the B file that's also now
like it I could just take it or this one
yeah this is this is a good one it
detects the a4 pond and if he takes with
any peace Knight takes bishop takes all
going to take an f3 yes I just take him
Bishop takes and then queen a form
Knight b6 I have queen e for taking the
rook
ya know I have this this pin on the
fourth-ranked yeah that's green white
resigned yeah like nothing I can do in
this 15 minutes time control the
opposition is usually somewhat weaker
but now it is very very very weak
comparison at least that is a good setup
we could show against the Hedgehog sorry
the Hedgehog set this this a chop set up
it is a good one against the London and
it's also something i recommended in a
series of videos that i did how to fight
the london system it's a notoriously
solid and slightly boring opening and
while this kind of play at least make
sure that you have many pieces on the
board and have some possibilities to to
complicate matters alright thanks for
watching and have a nice final hours of
christmas the CM thanks for watching